hey yo what up this ghetto and you can
catch me on a bootleg cab podcast let's
go
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here
that guy's on fire he's on fire right
now one of my favorites pz is here
Detroit's in the building thank you
brother I appreciate you kale it's dope
to see uh this because I've been
following you for a long time obviously
I've been tapped in since before you got
locked up and uh is super dope to see
you catch this hit record man
you know what I'm saying and now it
feels like everybody else is coming
around you know what I'm saying how do
you feel like because it's one thing to
have the catalog and to be able to go to
certain markets and pick up bags and and
to get those streaming checks but how
does it feel to have like a record like
a hit it feels good because of course it
feels good because
I've been rapping so long exactly and
it's like I watched everybody like
and there's no disrespect everybody in
the D that like blew up I kind of had
like personal relationship with them
like
you know what I'm saying so I watched
everybody go I watched everybody music
take off from the root you know what I'm
saying I was right there with all of
them and it had me kind of feeling like
maybe my music wasn't good enough you
know what I'm saying so I feel good to
finally be getting the recognition there
because I've been working hard for a lot
of years for sure man you've been
putting in work you know putting putting
so much catalog and obviously you know
the label free Rio uh you know I feel
like what you've been doing in building
um it's just dope to see everybody else
coming to the table now at the party I
guess you know what I mean and I also
feel like to the timing just for Detroit
is crazy right now because you catching
a hit at the same time that
feels like every label signing somebody
from Detroit oh yeah Detroit you got
baby face Ray you got Icewear Vezzo you
got baby man baby money TV baby Tron
baby Tron
um this is the list it's a lot a lot of
them it's a lot man everybody everybody
doing good
for you uh you've been a part of the
scene for so long I know a lot of you
know your personal issues aside but I
feel like a lot of the issues in Detroit
for the most part have been put to rest
and it feels as unified as I've seen it
in a while in terms of the top guys kind
of moving together that
um why do you think that is everyone's
kind of growing up a little or it just
feels like everyone's kind of moving in
the right direction
uh well it's two things
nobody got hurt you know what I'm saying
because that's hard to come back from
yeah it wasn't no blood behind our
situation and then another thing we are
older you know what I'm saying and we do
owe that to the city because it's like
everybody wanted to see that you know
like we want to see these guys come
together so bad
and it was just like time for it so as
we got older and everybody got kids and
we lost guys on our side they lost guys
on they said not from
like each other but just losing right
right it happens and it's like man we
need to put that [__] to the side
and just do this for the city and make
it look good and that's what we did and
now we actually get friends all of us no
I see it man it's dope to see and it's
dope to see like
you know a guy like yourself have to go
sit down for a little bit and then come
out and Thrive at a level higher than
you've ever thrived in your career and
on that same token a guy like I swear
Vezzo who had to do the same thing but
and and you guys it's just whenever I
talk to artists who aren't from Detroit
and I just we just talk about hip-hop's
landscape I always tell everybody like I
think right now Memphis got the got the
[__] it was hot but I do think Detroit
is on their ass Memphis hot with Detroit
you can't we we in there you know no
it's like for real and and even just
like the influence and like whether it's
the production or the flows I just feel
like
listen though right
and that is true but the sound that
everybody here
is a flint song it's not even Detroit
you did what I'm saying
you might hear more of a Rio and Mike or
try to make it sound yeah shout out to
Flint that was one of the best funniest
interviews I've ever done he's surprised
shout out to ree but the sound they're
like it's more fast it's more funny is
more that's really not a Detroit sound
shout out to bfv the Pac-Man you facts
that's my dude yeah that's my dude
but the signage are here like the the
funny the funny rap is like Fast yeah no
no like no choruses
that's really not a Detroit sound it's
more of a flint sign like real and Mike
in them was kind of like the four or
fives of that you know how's Rio doing
real excellent real super straight real
be home soon yeah dude do we know when
he's gonna be out no I can't even I
can't announce the date but he'll be on
soon yeah yeah that's a hell of a well
you you guys are a one-two punch man oh
man it's crazy yeah it's different like
me and bro together is millions on top
of millions
it's got to be like you get out
small period of time where you're out
and he's out and then he's got to go in
and then you that you got a hit so it's
like he probably seen that [__] from the
cell like bro bro you got one for real
like he's just sitting back and just you
know
I don't really know how to explain it
because we so used to
like
all right how can I say it because all I
want to say this in a way that
I've been having records like going yeah
in the streets are like yeah you got the
two million up it feels good to me but I
didn't allow myself to get over excited
because I had already kind of like been
used to knowing how to move with these
type records you feel what I'm saying so
it kind of kept me like on a humble like
so far as re I don't really know how to
explain it like how he feel about it
like me I'm still kind of like I don't
allow myself to get too excited about it
so we allow ourselves to stay home and
keep working the beat uh I talked to a
lot of hip-hop guys I forget which
rapper I just interviewed and they said
that it was like someone big who just
said that two million that was your
their favorite record I forget who the
[__] it was but that beat is infectious
that sample is crazy it's crazy how I
even got that beat because somebody else
was rapping on it when they sent it to
me I guess they wanted me to hear it and
put a verse on it or whatnot and I was
like yo let me get that wait so it got
sent to you to be a feature facts or I
think somebody may have wanted me to
hear it or
put a verse on it because they sent it
to me they had a verse on it or already
and [__] you know what I'm saying so
when I got it in my uh
email I'm like what the [__] you know
what I'm saying I'm gonna need that I
need that what happened to the guy whose
verse was on it oh no damn he probably
heard that [__] like [__] yeah he
probably did he probably hey I bet you
he's getting so much play though it
ain't even that though but you want to
know why because
anybody else could have made nobody
could have made the song I made facts
and I could no that's right so the beat
and it's the thing because I keep
telling the engineer who made the beat
because we had kind of like class you
know what I'm saying
because he had agreed to a number and I
ain't gonna say the number
and when it when the song blew up he
wanted more he ain't want to sign off on
the on the on what he agreed on and he
didn't have no team no lawyers and none
of that [__] before the song came out so
when the song like I did
here come a new manager and a lawyer and
all this [__] you know what I'm saying
with these numbers and [__] but we ended
up working it out but I'm telling him
like bro
you made the beat but it was the we paid
this it was a sample in the beat
and you had to clear the sample clear
the sample you had a paper so you had to
add okay some little bills and whistles
or whatever we can't take that away from
you but you could have gave that beat to
anybody else and it wouldn't have been
the song that I made you feel what I'm
saying so you can't sit up here and act
like you did something that you know
what I'm trying to say so if somebody
let's say like that particular guy is he
kind of can would you work with him
again no that's fair no I won't work
with him again I won't I don't like
working I really
I want to work with like in-house
producers man because it's tricky it's
different now it made it so difficult to
put out music right now it's like crazy
right to where you don't even want to
deal with producers if you don't
personally you know you know what I'm
saying yeah because then yeah now I feel
you because you we might we might have a
discussion in the studio and it's one
thing and then that lawyer drops that
email over but I ain't mad at I'm not
mad at how how I set up because the
producers do need their money in their
credit but sure how they got it set up
now
they allowing like lower level engine
lower level producers in to tars
like crazy numbers
based on based on who they think the
artist is right I think also too like
you got to look at like anybody not even
a producers artists anybody you gotta
like people should look at things the
Long play way
because like imagine if he would have
just been squared up with you and and
honored his word like we would have did
a whole album or something you know what
I'm saying [__] we made a hit together
let's make some more or orders or
they doing this too like they give you
the beat and it says free or not but
when it's time to put the record out
they're gonna charge
sixth seventh all right bro you know
what I'm saying yeah like you've never
made that much money for a beat they're
sending it on the invoice though like
hoping the label pair
you know what I'm saying like It's
Tricky [__] but not sure you still got
to pay you got to pay for that yeah yeah
but I'll be going for that [__] though
I'll call the engineer as my producer
myself like yo come on bro right that
[__] coming out of my pocket do you help
me out I'll help you out uh your opinion
the best Coney Island in Detroit uh L
George is on Six Mile and
it's on the west side too you know from
the East side right so you got to say L
George is on Six Mile and I think
Shaffer
yeah we went to uh Bronx in the Bronx
somebody told us to go to a place that
was by truth it was a a drive a drive
through you talking about a Nikki Nikki
that [__] was terrible that's it that
[__] was not good right across the
street at the corner yep on the corner
yeah not it first first like literally
the first Coney Island ever went to
they're like yeah go to the corner not
it they just told you to go there maybe
because you was close yeah maybe it was
on Eight Mile right but yep that's it
yeah yeah Eight Mile a month I was on
some real
I went to Eminem's trailer park when I
was in Detroit a lot of people want a
lot of people do that I was like oh [__]
I get it you know what's funny is like
uh
like I went to uh uh a Tech Nine concert
out there
and I saw
the Detroit white trash
and in that moment I understood the
whole Eminem thing fully because I was
like oh these this is just a a venue
full of uh M Ms that didn't make it
because they got their world over there
they do you don't know about it yeah we
just ride up Eight Mile and we see them
trailer parks but we don't know what's
going on you know what I'm saying it's
pretty crazy man I will say this though
like I think uh you know I spent about
six or seven days out there and I loved
it man in Detroit I loved it there
Detroit cool man I feel like I feel like
people gotta go that's right that's why
I like the most beautiful black women in
the world were there too yes we got nice
women in Detroit yeah yeah and everybody
hustlers in Detroit first you know what
I'm saying before anything like I know
you hear about a lot of [__] but
right
[__] get money females get money like
everybody is trying to get some money in
Detroit right and like you can go down
there and do whatever you want to do
nobody ain't looking for nobody y'all
you know what I'm saying yeah dude I I
had a great time red blue green like
yeah
Ace of Diamonds Ace of Spades Ace of
Spades Ace of Spades yeah we had a good
time it was a good night yeah you don't
have fun in Detroit especially in the
summertime you know what I love this you
bitching the hustling thing and I've
seen it it's funny because I've seen it
since then but I went to the liquor
store on the west side and they were
selling the empty uh weed bags like the
bootleg cookies bags and [__] at the at
the gas station I was like damn man and
people are going down just stuffing
[__] in these bags
like [__] I can't get the Cali
and get bags and [__] right but they
know packaging said we eat so if they
can get them down there at the gas
station why not yeah so I love so what's
up guys hey shout out to our family at
uh blue chew man listen I know we always
are getting feedback about our Bluetooth
interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's they're
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discreet package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just drop the
mint chewable same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so what you need to
do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you bud
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the hot Sox Basics baby yeah so look so
this was stuff about odd stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff oddsocksofficial.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you will save 20 off at checkout try the
odd Sox Basics if you're one of those
guys who wears other plain white branded
socks plain black socks I promise you go
with the odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro Stand Down be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
for you uh speak to I guess your
mentality
um I feel like when you get incarcerated
it puts you through some some mental
anguish oh man
um how did you have to like how were you
able to still stay motivated and still
stay
I guess like saying going through that
because you you get locked up and kind
of like at the peak of your career at
the time
um how do you how do you get on get out
on the other side of that and and and
work and be bigger and better than ever
well because I know I have a long time
right was a couple years like a year two
years yeah so
in that two years I'm like [__] I'm
gonna go ahead do what I need to do
because I know everything happened for a
reason you know what I'm saying even
though I went to jail for some serious
[__] right like I went to jail for what
everybody going to jail for now like the
RICO like I really went to jail for that
you know what I'm saying and I know I
was in jail for serious charges but it
went for long because I didn't have a
criminal record so right and that time I
read books like I never read you know
what I'm saying
I live I dropped out of school in the
11th grade I didn't say I dropped out
like I dropped out of high school like I
dropped on 11th grade I went right
circumstances at home was kind of like
rough so I stopped going
but uh I went to school up until the
11th grade and uh what the [__] was I
saying uh you're talking about how you
just started to read you were reading in
jail I was reading so I started by
Reading Writing getting my hand writing
back because I sat in the hole for three
months so in that time like I had to I
couldn't do number right 23 hours a day
24 hours a day in a pandemic oh you know
coming up really facts and you got a
sale mate
it's crazy and you're just in there with
the dudes it's in there non-stop nah
stop and don't you know how they say you
know two days the same yeah every day
the same [__] man every day the same but
what you do get is is a piece of mind
you learn yourself
you sit back and it's quiet and you
figure out like what the [__] am I doing
back here
where I like what did I do like you know
what I'm saying and you thinking you
figure it out like I never I cannot
never come back
do you end up getting closer to this
helmet
you want to know something funny
I don't know if you know
um I don't even know if you remember
like the guy that went viral in the
pandemic for like making a jail video
and [__] yeah he was my cell mate in
there oh really facts that's crazy man
when they put me in there with him
I was like yo what the [__] they
premiering with this guy for because I
got caught with a cell phone right
and it was weird as [__] I checked the
whole room for bugs and [__] I'm like
man it's they put me here they trying to
trap me and [__] but yeah you ended up
being cool as [__] hella intelligent
like reading man got books stacked to
the
yeah
so you were able you were able to like
kind of readjust some here you know like
I mean you really ain't got [__] else to
do but read
a bunch of reps
you know I I don't write so when I got
in there I'm like I gotta write some
music at least see on a normal basis you
do punching in yeah so in jail you got
books of Rhymes now I wrote like 40 raps
in there that's crazy yeah that's 40
songs though you recorded them I
recorded Maybe
10 of them that's hey that's not a bad
ratio I recorded maybe 10. this heat in
there though I got heat in there I don't
doubt it but I don't I just don't
remember where exactly because I moved
into three different cribs um you can't
write to the beat maybe you got a beat
in your head no when I came home I was
making that [__] go to beats like I just
had so many of them I'm like whatever go
to a Beat
so that's a jail record
okay I wrote that until my last intro on
a free real album I wrote that in jail
uh
a couple more of them I wrote an arcade
thing off the head what do you feel uh
you know obviously
as somebody who
was incarcerated for Mariko
and the RICO stuff is happening in
hip-hop obviously in Atlanta
um
and it feels like that the snitching
thing is a lot more prevalent than it's
ever been because paperwork is I guess
easy easier to get to I don't know but
like what are your thoughts on just like
how artists should move nowadays
not necessarily if they're officially
wrapped up in anything but it it feels
like the wrong the right people are
watching and I guess they're the wrong
people watching so it's like
for you like if you could give advice to
anybody
going through a RICO like you know what
would what for you like
what would be some advice you would give
some of these artists and and how should
people move man because I feel like
people move so flagrantly they put so
much [__] on the internet
but that is that's a serious charge bro
yeah especially it's a federal one
it is a federal charge and it's a state
charge but it's a serious [__] charge
you know what I'm saying especially
especially if you've been a prison of in
the in and out the system
you know what I'm saying right it's a
serious [__] charge it's hella
stressful
I've been through it and I went through
that [__] for almost two and a half
years before I went to jail me and all
my co-defense
um
we just live in like a time where like
everything is so serious like
nobody don't want to hear lies or like
[__]
so these guys is like willing to throw
it all in the line for like some extreme
credibility
situation like it works until you yeah
yeah you might go platinum but then you
might go sit down then you might you
might lose it all and it's risky you
know what I'm saying and then and the
question is all right is it worth it I
think the internet too desensitizes
every like we're all desensitized to
like real consequences because so many
people could just do [__] on the
internet and it doesn't affect them they
don't think it affects them and I think
everybody yeah
these charges man like
like what am I like two of my Cody
finishes fighting definitely you feel me
one of my co-defendants got 30 to 60
years plus 15 Jesus
two of my Cody fans got nine years one
of them got eight
two of us got two years like you know
what I'm saying
none of us uh
cooperated or did nothing like that we
all went to court together right
I don't speak on nobody else cases I
don't know what I'm saying
I think that's kind of like the if if
they bring those charges against you
they're kind of hoping that it's like a
numbers game like if we get 20 of these
guys like me all we need is a wonderful
what it is is that
with us
it was like these guys animals get these
guys off the street
I wasn't even in a I wasn't in none of
them I just scared every like no paper
you know what I'm saying
but they like [__] they all get them all
you don't have to be doing nothing but
if you over there and if you've seen
with these guys and if you've known for
posting these guys on your page or
friends or not you in the loop
you feel what I'm saying you in the loot
now no matter what you did because they
can make him say you did something
foreign
that's crazy that's that's that's what's
crazy it's like I don't know what the
[__] that is I'm serious yeah you know
what I'm saying so
in order to dodge these situations you
gotta start by having fun with music
like everybody want to kill each other
like
[__] all that you know what I'm saying
like [__] all that like
I like flash it like you know
it's so fun flying somewhere and going
shopping and living in the best hotels
and swimming and
pools on top of
you know what I'm saying like a lot of
these young [__] will never see that
right because they they living so
serious you gotta have some fun that's
the only way to die is to start back
having fun and also the Dodge like like
that gives you some peace just have fun
like come on man like I feel like
everybody's trying to prove something a
lot of [__] can't be taken back in the
street man I get it like you know what
I'm saying but it's it used to be a time
and a place for [__] like the internet
ain't for
it's not for that like they bring them
they bring that [__] there and it's
[__] the game up it's really [__]
the game up and we all did it we all
made mistakes like nobody perfect you
know of course of course everybody got
caught up in the moment and did some
internet [__] you know what I'm saying
but us as a whole
and uh we [__] the game up bringing
the street [__] to the internet right
for you making it so easy for them and
then I could cut you off but
when these [__] get these Rico charges
a lot of them never had money
you feel what I'm saying
a lot of these [__] don't got nothing
when they go to jail but
they ride around these guns and these
cars and do this option they go to jail
and then they they don't got nothing you
know what I'm saying yeah
isn't no I see it all the time man even
like people who aren't artists just like
normal people get some money yeah so
when you do get these charges you don't
got to be caught alone tomorrow man
[__] fake [__] I ain't never calling
that car home for [__] when I was in
jail I had my money put up I had my [__]
put in places and and I had two
trustworthy people who I knew was gonna
move for me right I ain't had to call
them have nobody for the [__] so
whatever I was already doing I could
stand it I could get in trouble I can
get myself out of it my lawyer money and
I ain't never had the car also
these [__] get in trouble and they
don't got no money it's bad for sure
um
suspensive in jail bro what's up y'all
bootleg Kev here hey look my boogie man
it's a big weekend in sports the big
game is Sunday Chiefs versus Eagles I'm
all in on the Eagles
I like Jalen hurts over on the passing
yards over on the rushing yards anytime
touchdown score give me Dallas got her
anytime touchdown score give me the over
and if anyone on the Chiefs is going to
score I like that Pacheco kid I like the
little running back guy and of course
you gotta Hammer Travis Kelsey anytime
touchdown score you can do all that at
my bookie right now all right so many
props to bet on at my bookie this
weekend you can bet on the Gatorade
color that gets poured out you could bet
on the on the flip the the coin flip the
beginning of the game all that right now
at my bookie sign up with the promo code
bootleg when you sign up they will match
your very first deposit up to one
thousand dollars with that promo code
bootleg so go to mybookie.ag sign up for
an account
promo code bootleg whatever you put in
they're gonna double it
as long as it's not more than a thousand
you put 999 dollars in they're gonna
give you another 9.99
you put a thousand in they gave you
another thousand by the way if you do
the 9.99 why not just do the full
thousand you cheap bastard anyway my
bookie right now man it's a big weekend
also I just would like to point out
everyone should be putting some of that
money sprinkling a little bit of that
action on the Phoenix Suns win the
championship this year because we have
Kevin Durant oh yeah oh yeah my bookie
signed up with that promo code bootleg
also shout out to our family at hardean
hardeen Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with
Jardine you got to follow him at Harding
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas
have I mean obviously there's a huge
disconnect from like
uh when I was growing up the Detroit
hip-hop that I was listening to was like
J dilla
Eminem
uh Royce for slum Village you know um
and and I felt like the street [__] had
the first kind of like National time
that like some real dope ill Street [__]
from Detroit hit my radar was dope was
cash out with when they signed with CTE
and
um and then I kind of feel like
first day out kind of like busted the
gate open for that genre of Detroit
hip-hop nationally but how do you see
like
Detroit's hip hop landscape like if you
could give me like the top give me like
your your Mount Rushmore Detroit hip-hop
because there's so many different oh man
there's just so many different layers of
Detroit's scene
damn
that's crazy nobody never asked me this
excluding yourself it's glued on myself
you can't say you that's true I have to
say me you can't though okay you can't
say you
all right but on
even if I if I don't say me it's like um
all right first and foremost blade
icewood okay rest in peace
Street lure wine okay
Eminem
payroll Giovanni mm-hmm
one more I need two more okay give me
two more
I just wear Vezzo and Babyface Ray
I like that I like that you you kind of
covered all spectrums
shots a little late too who's doing this
thing man uh okay so for you do you feel
any pressure to follow up no you're just
gonna keep dropping I just do me bro do
you because that's what you do I'm gonna
be in the like people make Detroit
listening [__] I don't get involved in
that like I don't comment on it because
it's like they do that [__] to like make
fans pick and choose right right right I
just do not just go put music I'll be
happy for everybody well you've always
like stayed independent and been rocking
with Empire and like you know obviously
shots of guys and shout out to Nema and
the team over there I'm assuming you've
had situations that have come up where
One of the quote unquote majors has
tried to get you to kind of sign your
[__] life away and sign your catalog
away but
um well nobody really never came to me
like that really not even now
you know we don't be coming at me like
that I guess I got the aura of just like
that like we won't wait
yeah you can't like you know what I'm
saying because nobody really never tried
to like come at me in that time I was
gonna say like kind of just speak to
like
what you've learned from working with
gazi well I I learned a business from
bumping my head
I learned a lot about this game like a
lot of ends and all [__] about this game
too where I probably won't sign right
you know what I'm saying
it's a lot of money in this game if you
can hold still this [__] like stop build
up your Leverage
yeah it is like stock right it's almost
like that's why I think it's important
to like have like a high output and it's
important to build your catalog like
shout out to uh Source worker because he
was saying like every song is a property
and you're right because every song
stream every song make money so I'm
gonna hit your account every month don't
make don't catch a hit yeah because
that's two three hits yeah you feel what
I'm saying so it's just about holding
still like not selling out you know what
I'm saying and me learning that
when it's time for me to like
going to renegotiate what's going we're
gonna have to really renegotiate you
know what I'm saying in fact for sure
man uh well listen it is Super Bowl
weekend we're in Arizona you got a show
tonight yeah I got a show tonight I'm in
uh I got my [__] going on tonight we got
to sit down and do this for like two
hours in L.A whenever you're ready bro
you don't do a lot of interviews I don't
do a lot of interviews but I but you
want to know I I I want to start kicking
it I want to start kicking it because I
wanna trust me I was in Detroit and like
the main purpose of me going to Detroit
was to record content with you but I
don't know what the [__] was going on at
the time Detroit crazy
whatever it was it was like yo peasy's
not he's not doing nothing this week I
was like well [__] let me figure some
[__] out
was it cold no it was really it wasn't
it was in uh
it was during the playoffs it was after
it was game seven when the Mavericks
destroyed my Phoenix Suns and I lost the
thousand dollars at the MGM at [__]
in Detroit I forget so what was that
June July
um
brother but do you do mushrooms yes nice
yes I think someone said you were
shrooming that week I could have missed
room in that week that might have been
the week yeah they were like he ate a
lot of mushrooms he's not available
real bad damn real bad I tore the whole
house up I broke everything in that
business then I was like damn I gotta go
about all this [__] again I actually
think that's when I was there
that's when you was there I think I
heard about it that's when I [__] up
to everything so you was just [__]
wallet and I had a good time off these
rooms before I got home right I had a
great time before I got home the worst
part about shrooms is like if some if
you could be feeling great and like I've
had my girl press me while I'm tripping
out of town and it just like melts my
brain and them shits make me talk too
much and made me cry too much they
definitely will make you cry
what do you cry like what is it because
you just think you think about
everything and it just I'm just like I'm
an emotional I'm a Scorpio yeah you know
what I'm saying so I don't really I
don't really cry a lot right but I do
cry a lot you know what I'm saying so if
I get off the mushroom and I get
emotional I'm gonna let that [__] out
have you ever done you might be talking
to one of my peoples and just break down
I I just saw uh one of my friends baby
Joel uh I ain't seen him in a while and
I was on mushrooms and I just looked at
him and I started crying I was like I
[__] love you bro yeah I want you to
know like I really love you when I say
that [__] dog they make you so happy
like they make you nice and hate people
like have you smoked a DMT no I don't
smoke what is that oh man you gotta [__]
with that that's that [__] Mike Tyson
and Joe Rogan be doing I don't see Mike
Tyson getting too high like Tyson a real
Stoner hey I read Mike Tyson booked
three times when I was in the hoes you
got to go on History Tyson the dopest
DMT is like a it's like a chemical that
your body produces twice there's like a
gland right here
it produces it when you're born and when
you're dead when you die
so there's smoke that there's a frog
that sweats it
so
you
you smoke it
um in the like it's crackheadish right
so you have to free base it to get the
best experience right and you just go
away for 15 minutes
there you go you're in like a different
dimension what kind of experience you
had I haven't done it yet I'm scared you
want to try it I do badly I will I will
do it one day I'll be ready you've done
it oh yeah you just you liked it it's
like mushrooms
oh man and I see so I have burnt on
whippets like that whippers use that oh
no whippets are crazy
Jesus I was the first person doing the
whippers in Detroit
did you stop yeah you just I couldn't
breathe like I I smashed cars off this
like out of that [__] was there so the
whippets are like because I've had
rappers come in with those boxes of
whippets yo
I had rappers come in with the boxes of
the whippets
and right before that I mean I'm talking
canisters just all over the ground that
was you that was me yeah yeah what's
that is because it's a quick it's like
quick and it goes away so you got to
keep hitting it
man I remember one day
uh I went to drop my mans off at home I
dropped him off to the grip
and I never left the career like he went
in I never pulled off
it was crazy
what made you stop man
because they I couldn't they was like
[__] my breathing up I couldn't
perform it I couldn't really perform off
of them and that [__] was just like
stupid man yeah it's like it's like a
1990s 2000s One Drug so I used to ride
around with the tank though with the
balloons holy [__] my escalator you get
pulled over like yeah you know I have a
party business you know I never knew
that that [__] was illegal
I never knew that like nobody never told
me like you can't ride around with a
tank of helium in your girl I didn't
know that either well hey guys you
learned a lot on this interview
well allegedly you had it in your car
yeah pz's in the building appreciate you
for pulling up man I look forward to
doing this again in La at my place I'm
coming to La man Los Angeles we'll be
there you did yes sir appreciate you yes
sir all right boom